well there we've got to do we got to do
one more quick segment before we jump
over the superchips that quick I'm just
a little excited about so we're gonna be
talking about the new PS 5 I don't know
who saw the so PlayStation actually push
this back this was supposed to happen
two weeks or like I don't know when did
the riots start wait like May 4 May 28th
27th or something or when it started
yeah 20 feigning right Oh 27th I believe
so the 27th so they were supposed to
have this and they pushed it back and
they're like you know what we gotta wait
and and today was finally the reveal two
million people live they were we're
hosting alive there was a two million
people peak and it was awesome so check
us out here we go the million concurrent
two million concurrent people they're
watching us the PlayStation 5 so here's
the first the first few things we got to
get to for those that are just tuning in
what's up well the the weird game
controversy oh yeah but but there's a
bunch of games we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna look at some of the games
that are coming out cuz some look
awesome like horizon zero dawn part 2
yeah and spider-man and some PT human
souls remaster actually I don't know if
it's a remake or a remaster they're not
really specific on that but they're
saying there's some new things that
they're adding so I don't know if it's
an actual remaster might be a remake
which I'm I'm actually really for if
they they remaster it with some tweaks
that sounds the best so yeah I also know
this year PS 5 so you can see here this
is the the new PS 5 console with the new
controller and you can actually lay it
on inside it doesn't look like you can't
but I think it's sitting on a stand here
but I've seen it sideways so you can
actually lay it down on side everyone's
I mean people are making up all sorts of
random memes now with this somebody said
it looks like a Wi-Fi router yeah yeah
but it's you know it's an electronic
device so how they're all kind of
similar you know in the long run so
nothing good about it apparently it's
got like new tech or something so it's
got its got a mazing SSD drive that's
supposedly better than anything that's
out there and it's a hundred times
faster than the ps4 which is that's
insane there's no loading times none and
it's just driven no SSD is solid safe
because I see it isn't there just drive
that's that's for
the blue rays slice yes for games they
you can still play piano everything's
gonna be digital and actually it comes
with a digital version that doesn't have
a slot so you can you can get it without
the slot it'll probably be like a
hundred bucks cheaper if I were to guess
so cuz they'll include the blu-ray
player but we don't we don't know the
prices there's lots of guesstimating
everyone's going Oh 500 does 700 others
that's kind of like the I had a tweet
and that's pretty much the consensus
somewhere between I wouldn't be
surprised if it's $5.99 but that sounds
about right to me that's high though
yeah I mean it's it's the next-gen it's
it is it does seem high but people are
gonna pay for it
they're gonna want it they they want to
I mean two million people were or
eagerly yearly watching this yeah so
let's let's let's we've got the don't
take a look at the games here we go so
we got all this is the PlayStation
YouTube page and it basically just has
all the trailers split into individuals
so we can we can see all the games and
and the one I'm most excited is
absolutely the Demon Souls game that
looks a little incredible really excited
about that
horizon forbidden West looks really dope
that's the rise into zero dawn sequel
the NBA 2k one looks really good I don't
play basketball games but a buddy of
mine does so I I'm always interested in
anything friends of mine play some
buddies look pretty cool I need to watch
these though I haven't seen all that one
right there alright so on so grand theft
auto 5 they're redoing grand they're not
making grand theft auto 6 they're just
enhancing grand theft auto that's why
it's all thumbs down look at that like
to dislike ratio oh wow yeah look at
that remember when Rockstar used to make
games man Rockstar has been milking that
game for way to Rockstar if it ain't
broke don't fix is a message for you
stop milk in that game give Red Dead
Redemption do some more love no make GTA
6 like everybody wants please no listen
man if it isn't broke don't fix it
they're making fat cash off that game
why stop now
I mean in in their defense they have
consistently brought new stuff into GTA
5 non-stop throughout the past six years
seven years when did that game come on I
knew it
eight years ago now I don't know it's
been out for a long time
and they just dropped some new stuff
last year so constantly they're adding
new stuff it's pretty cool what's this
thing about like some sjw games I don't
even see it where is my hair go up let
me see it it's right here I don't know
if it's sjw I don't know what exactly is
it oh here we go volcano hi this looks
like some whoa this thing's getting
nuked hard looks like a Simo furry lands
no yeah I don't watch it or eating it in
trouble well yeah we probably can't play
the whole thing by the show like it
looks pretty bad it look it looks like a
bunch of sad furries crying looks like
somebody tight with tumblr avatars and
made it into a cartoon they burned their
yearbook goodbye volcano hi they burned
the book I mean look there's some some
deep in thought emo emo it really does
look like tumblr you know like come to
life you know one thing I'm a little
annoyed at people go back a page like
yeah yeah so there's a new spider-man
and yeah it looks really cool it looks
awesome
everyone loved spider-man when it came
out for ps4 and now they're they're all
there's there's it's a Myles Moranis
malice oh excuse me miles morale there
we go and it looks dope this game and I
really everybody likes this look at this
this is totally thumbs up oh that's
great that's great yeah well I mean I
was I was reading on Twitter I'm you
know so I'm looking through and there's
some people out there and it's not just
about this it's you know I'm gonna bring
other games into my point here but
they're they're upset because it's not
Peter Parker it's not spider-man and I'm
like yeah but did you see into the
spider-verse the movie was awesome good
movie for one it was a great spider-man
movie and it makes sense
well his character it's not like they're
just shoving you know I'm minority in in
someone else's shoes no I think it's if
they're gonna do it this is kind of the
best way that they did it it's cool it's
a multiverse it makes sense he has a
spider his own storyline of how he
became spider-man I like it I dig it
they already had like I'm excited about
it they already had like a spider verse
right you know a long time ago I don't
know when the original comic or whatever
came out or you know but I remember when
I was growing up watching the spider-man
show the spider verse so sure sure you
could make a bunch of different you know
spider-man type characters but I do
think it is extremely lazy when they do
hand me
characters well that's kind of what's
happening with Ratchet and Clank so
there's a new Ratchet and Clank game
this actually looks really smooth the
the gameplay looked really pretty and
then at the very end they warp to a new
plane and ratchet becomes a girl wait
what yeah so it's like wait a minute is
it ratchet or is it this like Chetta I
don't know it was right at the very end
seriously right at the right at the end
they lands I'm just gonna play this one
scene boom huh
so it's like it's not ratchet wait is it
is it ratchet or is it not I don't never
played Reggie but this is this is what
people are complaining about they're
like why wouldn't you just do something
new why would why are you gonna try to
shove you know and replace and that are
they replacing though or are they adding
a new character I have no idea I like to
jump to conclusions this one also got a
thumbs up and I thought Gretchen Clank
people love it and honestly this game
looked so high this is not my type of
game it's very colorful also it looks
really fun I was like oh man baby maybe
I'll play this game it does it looked
really smooth it felt like a next-gen
game what do you what do you think's
gonna happen with last of us - I
honestly I don't even think about that
game a lot of people are like yeah why
did they even need a second one the
first one came to a conclusion it was a
great story what is the second one even
about then they're they're censoring
people that are DMCA takedowns I'm
people who are talking about it even
yeah and I'm hearing like the game is
gone like sjw something I honestly I
don't follow a lot of these criticisms
of these games okay I know I'm not gonna
play it anyway my thing is all like that
that volcano High thing where it looks
like tumblr Bobby so big does it looks
really bad and everybody seems to hate
it yeah but I don't care whatever I'm
just not gonna buy it yeah so you know
that's what I say it's like listen man
let them do their skin soup thing mm-hmm
where they take the the withered husk of
what what used to be and then they drape
it over their bodies and prop it up and
let them let them prop it up I don't
know I'm gonna I'm gonna ignore it and
it's not gonna get money from me yeah I
guess there is the problem though that
like when it comes to these SJW type
takeovers of intellectual property or
institutions okay they get money from
external sources and sometimes through
force like through taxpayer funds that's
when it gets scary
yeah propping up things that can't
succeed that everyone hates by forcing
them to pay for it I'm not gonna be a
fan of that but I don't know if you've
noticed have you notice any other
interesting games they welcome resident
Resident Evil 8 cool is coming out it
looks beautiful and yeah the the earlier
Resident Evil games always annoyed me
because of the camera angle force you
know you you don't control the camera
angle it's a static shot that always
bugged me so I just never could get into
Resident Evil games
apparently bug snacks it's really bad oh
that load it looked but interval they
gotta make games for kids though man
come on I yeah sure but it's when you're
when we're waiting for this we've been
they've been toying with us
ps5 reveal these epic new games amazing
graphics and you see this just click to
any any screenshot do the graphics look
like 1999 CGI Kids program
yes exactly 10 this is the PS 5 so when
I was to pay for this yes so when I saw
this I was like what is this it was a it
started with this strawberry with googly
eyes popping out of the ground and like
and then it gets eaten by that vent
walrus bear I don't know what that thing
was but hamburger is that a sub sandwich
it looks like a sub sandwich snake I
don't know now I will say the CGI looks
really really bad but somehow still kind
of good like because of the lighting
exactly the lighting makes everything
the lighting is good and everything else
is just awful exactly this it looks like
someone built it on unity and was like
oh man we could just add these new
lighting effects and it'll be great and
it's like yeah but that's not what we
want
we've had these games for a long time I
want something no lighting Dalene a new
to make it what look like I'm I'm
looking into a world that I can believe
and I don't get that here I mean yes
sure it's for kids right what's what
good point
kid a kid's gonna be like this is great
I'm a walrus eating strawberries well
what's that what you know you know that
game where you play a little like a
little guy and you can press L&R and as
arms goes up and then he jumps and you
can like climb things and it's like the
controls are all
a wacky what's that game called no no no
it's a 3d game it's a lot of fun I'm
sure everybody knows what it is you
start with a character that's just like
a white model and you can add beanies
and shirts and hats and stuff and then
it's the reason to bring that came up
and I'm sure something I'm gonna see in
the chat pop up in two seconds is
because the graphics are trash it's a
really really fun game so you can play
online multiplayer and you can you you
when you press right right or left his
arms go up okay and then you can touch
the walls and he grips huh but you can
also grab other people and then like
drag them and then like they try and
grab and stop you and then it's people I
love playing that game because it's
always like little kids screeching so
look like look at this game though this
is the new LittleBigPlanet it's
basically a little big planet for this
is for kids also this is a human fall
flat yeah someone good yeah nice flat so
this now this game the graphics are
amazing I'm gonna just play a little
clip you can't even see how good the
graphics looked because this is like
through a screen through a screen
through a screen now but this is what
I'm talking about this is a kids game
this looks it's it's kind of like
because LittleBigPlanet was a
side-scrolling game we write with a
little bit of depth but now it's like
full 3d environments it's cool it's dope
it's like this is the evolution that we
were expecting to see for kids game not
that other stuff that looked like some
somebody's first development project
like oh cool you made a game you should
have released it on Steam first and you
know then built your way up to PS 5 the
PS 5 reveal it would some of these games
are mad really disappointing I was
expecting PS 5 to be like you're looking
through a window when you play the game
like Gran Turismo 7 looked amazing that
that is exactly what you'd expect like
looking through looking through the
window you're like wow I feel like I'm
driving this this car and they showed
like a lap around a race and look you
know what oh you know man so clean that
volcano hi I guarantee they were
thinking about their release games and
how they're gonna maximize sales mmm-hmm
there are so many game we got to catch
these emo users yes they're like what
about the you know 14 year old tumblr
market no for real because you think
about the animations of that game and it
looks really really bad okay like it
just does not look good and then you
look at the triple a top tier gay
like you know horizon or whatever mm-hm
and you can tell they're targeting as
many demographics as possible with
launch I can respect that but I can see
why people don't like that because that
game should not be the PS 5 well if s
that game design a ps1 you actually had
to type in your birthday and be 18 years
old or older to finish this what when
you entered it in like I went to
PlayStation they're like whoa whoa are
you of age to watch this video and I'm
like I did my fake birthday right just
cuz I never do much I'm a hundred and
twenty years old well no I'm I actually
do my correct year but all right it's a
different birthday every every time I
put it in but but I was like oh that's
weird like why would they do that oh it
must be because they're gonna be showing
these epic awesome games yeah cuz I when
I think PlayStation 5 I don't think like
an 8 year olds gonna be like I want the
new Playstation 5 I don't know it
doesn't feel like you know I think
Nintendo and I think little kids you
know yeah yeah but I'm you know I'm I'm
not a pro I mean at gaming so like sure
these are just my opinions but when I
watch that when's that coming out just
this fall yeah should be four before
Christmas although they did make an
announcement that there's gonna be less
PS 5s on release than ps4 they had
unreleased and because of Kovan yeah so
they just couldn't make as many so it's
I'm gonna it's gonna sell out yeah man
like that was already I haven't seen it
supposedly in the UK some people were
able to pre-order it on Amazon which is
odd and it went for 599 pounds which is
about seven our bucks yeah interesting
so we'll see we will see how it plays
out yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you